[Música]
venezuela sea el primer país de américa
latina al que la corte penal
internacional abre una investigación
formal esto quiere decir que la corte
buscará determinar la veracidad de los
supuestos crímenes de lesa humanidad
cometidos en venezuela desde al menos el
año 2017 es la primera vez que la cpi
abre una investigación en la fase en
esta fase en américa latina' recordemos
que 2017 fue un año de protestas en las
que parte de la población venezolana
sale a las calles para entre otras cosas
manifestar su descontento por la escasez
de comida la inflación y la inseguridad
además de la suspensión de un referendo
revocatorio contra el actual presidente
nicolás maduro para ello ya me acompaña
en el estudio alejandro cuerdo sus
capiteles doctor en historia politólogo
profesor de la política y relaciones
internacionales el universo de la
universidad sergio arboleda en colombia
alejando gracias por estar que con
nosotros en directo américa muy buen día
y le empiezo entonces se preguntando qué
significa este cambio de examen
preliminar a investigación contra
venezuela'
gracias raúl bueno
básicamente que venezuela se ha aislado
que venezuela no forma parte digamos del
de los países poderosos energéticamente
hablando te va a decir por qué porque el
hecho de que venezuela haya salido ya de
su protagonismo petrolero por las
dimensiones de catástrofe en la empresa
petrolera la excluyen del club de los
poderosos ya no particularmente de la
opep porque te lo digo porque la cpi nos
juzga quien quiere sino quien puede
entonces el hecho de que venezuela éste
esté en el radar de la cpi la sitúa más
cerca de los países africanos que de
hecho la cpi se ha intervenido mucho más
en áfrica tanto así que hay un bloque
liderado por kenia donde están tratando
de de mellar esa es esa de esa fijación
de la cpi en el espacio africano son los
presidentes de bueno en ejercicio han
sido juzgado presidente en ejercicio de
costa de marfil y de sudán entonces en
esa dinámica venezuela pareciera estar
más cerca ahora además de sus prácticas
nuestra activistas mineras pareciera
estar ahora más cerca de áfrica que de
sus vecinos regionales
ahora alejandro también el exceso de los
abusos cometidos por las fuerzas del
orden fueron duramente criticados por
organizaciones internacionales de los
derechos humanos cuáles casos en
particular serían investigados o no
cuáles son estas presuntas torturas
estos casos de abuso de la fuerza
policial de seguridad del gobierno y
nicolás maduro que la cpi está poniendo
el ojo bueno el fiscal jefe can está
haciendo la investigación preliminar
porque recuerda que la cpi debe empezar
el juicio tipificando muy bien el crimen
para que en su etapa final si es que
llega a suceder sea la misma causa que
se está investigando del principio si la
investigación arroja otras cosas que se
podrían penar perfectamente de castigar
pero no son las que se tipificaron al
principio no tendría caso el juicio
ahora qué opciones se tiene el gobierno
del presidente nicolás maduro que además
en la visita de este fiscal a venezuela
dijo que no está de acuerdo pero sí en
efecto respetaba la opinión también no
vemos ahí como una apertura del gobierno
de nicolás maduro digamos a instancias
internacionales que teníamos años sin
ver es un fiscal de la cpi dentro de
venezuela más que mensaje le estaría
dando le estaría dando madura al mundo
con esto bueno es complicado porque
podríamos apostar a una apertura
obligado por el contexto recuerda que su
operador su máximo operador está siendo
interrogado en eeuu
y eso pues puede ser un gesto de
debilidad el hecho de abrirse a
semejante recuerda que la cpi también
tiene un tiene otra finalidad más allá
de una investigación que tenga un curso
exitoso también tiene que tener un
impacto mediático un impacto vamos a
decir de espectáculos para
para cumplir también un rol de disuadir
de disuadir el poder y el abuso del
poder y la violencia por parte del
estado del miembro del estado la cpi nos
busca estados la cpi juzga ciudadanos no
así no estén suscritos así sus estados
representantes no estén suscritos al
convenio de roma p al estatus de roma
pero el hecho de ver si esa apertura o
que se está quedando solo y ha perdido
pues el país ha perdido influencia el
estado venezolano ha perdido influencia
por su decrecimiento en el mundo
energético petrolero pues para mí es la
razón real de que no haya más opciones
no creo que sea una una nueva etapa del
madurado y bueno vamos a abrir nos vamos
a bajar la atención con el sistema
internacional yo creo que venezuela
también está pagando tantas pruebas que
ya ha hecho el sistema internacional no
es de chávez cuando visitó a
hussein en irak
yendo en contra del sistema recuerda que
ese momento será un paria este de hecho
no podía haber vuelos comerciales por
encima dirá que estaba completamente
aislado y chávez puso a prueba el
sistema internacional visitando la
ciudad estrechando lazos con irán una
amistad con libia cercana con gadafi
etcétera bueno creo que ya venezuela por
este decrecimiento en su protagonismo
energético petrolero está está pagando
las consecuencias de haber sido tan
desafiante al sistema ahora alejandro
esta investigación podría ser
determinante digamos nicolás maduro si
podría ser juzgado y algunos algunas
personas de su cúpula militar depende lo
que arroje esta investigación de la cpi
sí ciertamente el mismo hecho vuelvo al
principio es esta tendencia de que
venezuela se parezca un poco más a las
dinámicas internas externas de los
países africanos que han estado en la
mira de la cpi nos hacen pensar que si
esto puede tener consecuencias puedes
seguir caminando esta investigación pero
por otro lado también vamos podemos ver
otra dinámica clásica de este tipo de
espectáculos jurídicos legales
la justicia internacional tiene unos
límites tremendos pensamos que es por
cómo suena la corte penal internacional
creemos que no tiene límites no tiene
fronteras al contrario es bastante
frágil en qué sentido te lo digo en que
venezuela también tiene todavía lazos
con los poderosos no china-rusia
bielorrusia que está está en tu parrilla
hoy de análisis son países turquía son
países que seguramente además que son
detractores de la justicia internacional
de la cpi de hecho les quieran ser menos
vinculantes es un bloque que liderará en
rusia arabia saudita de eeuu y china
puede que también sea una alianza
interesante para disuadir la
investigación o 'love o una sentencia
final entonces bueno son los dos
panoramas que yo puedo plantearte ahora
alejandro porque dicen que es una
decisión histórica
porque es la primera vez que un fiscal
jefe para américa latina que comienza
una investigación
venezuela era un país
timonel en democracia con todos los
efectos anteriores que se pueden
mencionar pero una franca política de
respeto a los derechos humanos de
suscribir todos estos convenios todo
estos tratados de justicia vinculante
internacional y ahora vemos que
venezuela digamos la venezuela post
democrática está siendo víctima de toda
la cantidad de convenios que con los
cuales se comprometió la venezuela
democrática entonces sí yo creo que es
histórico y no sé hasta qué punto ya que
pero
lamentablemente es es parte del
argumento que te traigo hoy nos estamos
parecía de venezuela se está apareciendo
más a estas dinámicas internas externas
de república del congo república
democrática gracias a los países además
que viven en unas dinámicas extractos
mineras terribles
alejandro muchísimas gracias entonces
por analizar un poco lo que le espera a
venezuela y sobre todo a los que están
en el gobierno del presidente nicolás
maduro en cuanto a la cpi que abrió esta
fase de investigación con respecto a los
crímenes que se cometieron desde el año
2017 en estas protestas gracias a sandro
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa gracias raúl estamos conversando
con alejandro cardozo uscátegui doctor
en historia politólogo y profesor de
política y relaciones internacionales de
la universidad sergio arboleda